thank you gentlemen our next presenter
is the co-star of planes trains and
automobiles and he's also a very good
friend of mine and a very very funny
woman mr. John Candy
I left my dress at home and sorry good
evening
as a member of the WGA I was not allowed
to write my segment of the show
unfortunately however my eight-year-old
daughter Jennifer bailed me out and it
scripted it up for me so without further
ado hi I'm John Candy we're sorry that
the movie we wanted to win planes trains
and automobiles which was a good movie
it's not nominated but I bet everyone
liked it and so did I I think the
Academy Awards for letting me be here
Academy honey let's see makeup is hard
HRD yeah that's right
if you want to do makeup you should
practice first then try it on someone
and if the person likes it try it on
another person and one day you just
might win an award for best makeup thank
you honey
and now the nominations for makeup are
Harry and the Hendersons Rick Baker
Happy New Year
Bob ladies and the winner is
Rick Baker for Harry and the Hendersons
thank you well first of all like to
thank the Academy for having this
category and for allowing my work to
qualify for it
I'd like to thank Universal Amblin
Steven Spielberg bill dear dick vane for
making the movie
Allen da vo for his beautiful
photography Kevin Peter Hall not only
for his brilliant performance but for
his cooperation and for being seven feet
tall my crew
Tom Tim Jim Al Jack Laney camelus
Stewart Matt all the people who worked
so hard on Harry special thanks to my
wife and my parents for the love and
support and last but not least I'd like
to thank all of the great makeup artists
past and present especially dick Smith
for inspiring me to work hard to try and
become one of them thank you very much